now to washington where republicans are
encountering a challenge from within
over the identity of the party
congresswoman marjorie taylor green is
once again facing condemnation
this time from both parties for
comparing mass
mandates and vaccines to the holocaust
chris van cleave is on capitol hill
chris good morning
the congresswoman has been accused of
doing this for the attentions and
attention i'm sorry and it seems to be
working well
good morning there is bipartisan
agreement that the rhetoric coming out
of georgia congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green is wrong but
that's not stopping her in fact just
hours after being condemned by
republican leadership here on the hill
she doubled down congressman marjorie
taylor-green made this comparison on a
podcast
lashing out against house speaker nancy
pelosi's decision
requiring lawmakers to wear masks on the
house floor
we can look back at a time in history
where people were told to wear a gold
star
and they were definitely treated like
second-class
citizens so much so that they were put
in trains
and taken to gas chambers in nazi
germany
green followed up tuesday with a tweet
saying vaccinated employees get a
vaccination logo
just like the nazis forced jewish people
to wear a gold star
it prompted republican rebukes this is
one of a frequent outbursts that are
absolutely
outrageous and reprehensible i think we
should kick her out of the conference
prevent her from
you know coming to conference meetings
benefiting from conference materials
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
called her comments appalling
but there was no talk of consequences
brendan buck worked for two republican
house speakers
and says leadership has few tools left
frankly saying things like this right
now
continues to be rewarded in media
attention in fundraising
and having people talk about them that's
what that's what they're searching for
green is blaming democrats for the
outcry writing i'm sorry some of my
words make people uncomfortable
but this is what the american left is
all about chuck schumer
is the first jewish senate majority
leader these are
sickening reprehensible comments
and she should stop this vile
language immediately now at least one
democrat in the house is pushing to have
green
expelled another would like to seek a
censure resolution
however it's unclear if either of those
would ever make it to the floor for
a vote democrats did force a vote
stripping green of her committee
memberships earlier this year based on
previous comments they deemed offensive
as for green
she uses the controversy to fundraise
and she is raising millions of dollars
so there's no reason for her to stop
anthony
chris thank you